geschätzte damen und herren leuten an
dem es ist wohl eine der ehrenhaften
aber zugleich verantwortungsvollsten und
forderten aufgaben sich auf soldatinnen
soldaten und offiziere im staate und
seinem volk im dienste zu verpflichten
um diese aufgaben auch unter
schwierigsten bedingungen bewältigen und
den damit verbundenen täglichen neuen
herausforderungen begegnen zu können
wurden sie an der militärakademie und an
inländischen wie ausländischen
bildungseinrichtungen bestens
ausgebildet auch die miliz geschätzte
damen und herren leuten an der steht
künftig veränderungen bleibt allerdings
trotz der bevorstehenden einschnitte
integraler und fester bestandteil des
österreichischen bundesheeres mit klarem
auftrag wird die miliz in zukunft für
die präsenz organisation durch
reduzierung der aktiven komponente an
bedeutung gewinnen und letztendlich
wieder einmal mehr ein wesentlicher
stützpfeiler unserer einsätze im in und
ausland darstellen
das problem des österreichischen
bundesheeres geschätzte damen und herren
ist nicht zu viel personal wie immer
wieder in den zeitungen steht
davon hatte truppe zu wenig das problem
des bundesheeres sind auch nicht
fehlende oder mangelhafte konzepte das
bundesheer hat in den vergangenen zehn
jahren zahlreiche innovative und
zukunftsweisende konzepte vorgelegt
die umsetzung von konzepten allerdings
war und ist immer vom budget abhängig
das dafür notwendige geld wurde aber
nicht zur verfügung gestellt auch
erlaube ich mir das wort an alle
österreicherinnen und österreicher zu
richten und diese aufzufordern sich zum
bundesheer als integraler bestandteil
eines funktionierenden aber vor allem
sicheren und freien staates zu beginnen
zukünftig werden wir uns vermehrt die
frage stellen müssen was können wir noch
sind wir noch entstanden dass und das zu
tun
eines jedoch ist gewiss dass wir stets
bemüht sein werden die militärischen
kernaufgaben zu erhalten sowie den uns
anvertrauten soldatinnen und soldaten
eine möglichst hochwertige ausbildung zu
bieten
das ziel einen hohen kompetenz hat des
bundesheeres zum schutz der republik
österreich und seines volkes
sicherzustellen darf weder heute noch
morgen in vergessenheit geraten
geschätze damen und herren leuten an dem
ich gratuliere nochmals zu erfolgreichen
absolvierung der offiziersausbildung und
der damit verbundene beförderung zum
leutnant ich wünsche ihnen alles gute
und viel erfüllung für den schönen aber
auch sehr fordernden dienst an unserer
heimat
es lebe die theresianischen
militärakademie
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich
meine sehr geehrten damen meine sehr
geehrten herrn offiziere des ausrüstungs
jahrgangs 2014 ihre sorgfältige
ausbildung wurde darauf abgestellt sie
wurden darauf vorbereitet auch unter
besonderen psychischen und physischen
belastungen voll handlungsfähig zu sein
und sich der besonderen verantwortung
als führungspersönlichkeit stets bewusst
zu bleiben
sie beenden mit dem heutigen tag den
fachhochschul bachelor-studiengang
militärische führung
dazu gratuliere ich ihnen sehr sehr
herzlich und möchte ihnen gleichzeitig
dafür danken dass sie bereit sind sich
als berufsoffiziere in den dienst
unseres landes der republik österreich
zu stellen
diesen dank richtig auch an die leute
nannte des miliz standes die neben ihrem
zivilberuf als österreichische offiziere
dienen
ich freue mich einmal besonders auf
montag in der früh wenn ich mich beim
kroaten der gerade melden darf und dann
als stellvertretender company command
der stabskompanie eingeteilt werde auch
direkt verantwortung für die ausbildung
und würde für den dienst meiner männer
übernehmen darf